نبدا من تويتر ورئيس واخبارهم واليوم
الاخبار مو عن الرئيس الحالي اهل مصر لا
الخبر اليوم عن الرئيس السابق جاك دورسي
اللي من بعد سلسله من خمسه حلقات من
الفضائح واللي كشفها المسك عن اداره تويتر
السابقه
وفسادها وسماحها للسياسه بالضغط على
الشركه وتدخلها في امور كثيره واللي اخر
حلقاتها كانت عن الاشياء اللي صارت في
الخفاء لحظر حساب ترامب من بعد كل هذا خرج
جاك دورسي عن صمته وطلع وعلقلق وكتب صراحه
بيان طويل وحقيقه لو في عنوان واحد نلخص
فيه البيان راح يكون كان هذا خطا اي وحدي
وب- كامل جاك دوسي شال المسؤوليه واقرب
بذنبه ولكن وضح وكمان فسر ايش قصده بهذا
الكلام واخ كان
اللي قالوا انه غلط انه استسلم للضغوط
خاصه من بعد ما ناشط معين اشترى اسهم في
الشركه لكنه بيقول انه استسلم وما قاوم
لانه كان فاقد للامل تماما جاك دورسي في
المنشور الطويل ما ذكر اسم المستثمر
الناشط اللي قصده عنه لكن كل الترجيحات
بتقول انه المقصود بشركه اليه مانجمنت
بقياده جيسيكون اللي اشترى فيه 20 20
الحصه الاكبر من تويتر ب 387 مليون دولار
وقال انه من وقتها وهو بدا يخطط لمغادره
الشركه واصلا كان في كلام انه المستثمرين
الجدد هذول ما كانوا حابينوا وكانوا
بيطفوا وجعك انسحب بعدها من تويتر
جاء كمان قال انه اكبر اخطاء وكان انه
خلال الفتره اللي كان بيخطط فيها للمغادره
استمر في الاستثمار في بناء ادوات للتحكم
في حوارات الناس على تويتر بدلا من بناء
ادوات تعطي الناس القدره على التحكم في
حواراتهم بانفسهم